what were the prisoners making on Arcana
5 the season finale of Andor has a
post-credits stinger you may have missed
which answers that very question keep
watching to find out all the details
Disney's Andor occupies a special place
in the Star Wars timeline the prequel
movies ending with Revenge of the Sith
see the bureaucratic Galactic Republic
corrupted and taken over from within by
an individual using emergency rules and
parliamentary edicts designed to
consolidate power of course by the time
Star Wars A New Hope comes around the
Republic has been replaced by the Empire
which uses fear tactics and overwhelming
Firepower to suppress the scent the most
infamous example of this is the Death
Star a massive space structure capable
of destroying planets and being
occasionally mistaken for moons Andor is
nestled in the time before the original
Star Wars Trilogy and after the prequels
and or itself is a prequel to Rogue one
a Star Wars story which sees Cassian
Andor and jyn urso make a faithful
sacrifice in order to deliver the plans
for the Death Star to the Rebel Alliance
and the movie pretty much ends exactly
where A New Hope picks up with Darth
Vader pursuing the ship of Princess Leia
now that Andor has completed its first
season the ending Stinger helps bring a
greater Focus to this era of Star Wars
history and it certainly gives Cassian a
very specific reason hate the Empire and
its super weapons Pandora starts with
small enough Stakes as Cassian looks for
any clues to the location of his lost
sister on the planet to Moreland one
unfortunately he is shaken down by two
security officers which results in
Cassian killing both this starts off a
localized hunt for Cassian though soon
the Empire gets involved when it's
revealed that Cassian had access to an
imperial starpath unit an exceptionally
hard to get item that would allow one to
track Imperial vessels although Cassian
wants nothing to do with Rebels he
accepts a job on aldani which involves
stealing the Imperial payroll for an
entire sector completing his task
Cassian receives his massive payday and
decides to lay low unfortunately
Imperial forces are engaged in a
galaxy-wide Crackdown and is charged as
a vandal even though he is innocent
given a six-year prison sentence Cassian
is sent to narkina 5 an imperial prison
and industrial complex forced to work on
some unknown project Cassian and his
fellow inmates are kept in line by an
electrified floor eventually becomes
known that none of the prisoners are
getting a chance to leave even after her
sentences are up which causes Cassian to
organize the successful escape two
episodes later and after a bombastic
finale It's Finally Revealed what
Cassian and his fellow inmates were
working on the original Death Star this
Stinger post credit scene at the end of
the first season of Andor establishes
just how The Empire is able to create
its fearsome Planet destroying Weapon by
utilizing prisoners that may or may not
be innocent the Empire is able to create
a Workforce that cannot complain quit
leave or even tell others what they are
working on which would endanger the
Empire's doctrine of ruling through
secrets and fear as noted by the Sun the
original Death Star measures around 75
miles wide which for the math incline
results in a volume of 32 quadrillion
515 trillion 31 billion 575 million 312
203 cubic feet these numbers certainly
illustrate just how much effort had to
go into the clandestine project and how
long the Empire had been working on the
Planet Killer it's also important to
remember that the original design for
the Death Star came from the geonosians
during the events of attack of clones
another aspect to consider involving the
construction of the Death Star is that
by the Empire utilizing prison labor
they are able to harness a tremendous
amount of Labor that the Empire doesn't
need to worry about talking this is
probably another reason why none of the
other prisoners on archina 5 are allowed
to leave the Empire doesn't want to risk
anybody putting together what their
project is this makes sense considering
that planet killing weapons are probably
a tough sell to all but the most
stringent of Imperial supporters and
citizens this reveal though currently
unknown Cassian certainly helps
establish some of his motivation in
Rogue one Cassian throughout season 1 of
Andor certainly isn't committed to the
Rebel Alliance cause he simply wants to
get paid settle his debts find his
sister and be left in peace and he
doesn't love the empire in any sense he
certainly isn't trying to take down the
impressive regime of course by the Time
season 2 rolls around Cassian will be
much more dedicated to the cause
especially considering what his adopted
mother Marva said in a recorded message
after her death the teaser scene
featuring droids putting the Death Star
together at the end of Andor and the
fact that Cassian had been working on
the Death Star the entire time was
something that the series had always
been building towards speaking with
polygon showrunner Tony Gilroy said we
came up with the prison and the building
of the park pretty early on it was like
oh they should be building the Death
Star and then you know you follow it
forward and it's like oh you know what
we ought to show that so the visual
effects department just loved that idea
and they ran with it still it will be
interesting to see where season two of
Andor leads and how much Cassian will
change over the upcoming course of
events before the events of Rogue one
thank you